here's a tricky exponent's question we  have to simplify the square root of a  fraction where the numerator is 8 to the  power of 12 plus 4 to the power of 13  and the denominator is 8 to the power of  6 plus 4 to the power of 14. first  remember that 8 is equal to 2 to the  power of 3 so we can substitute in  then 4 is equal to 2 to the power of 2  so we substitute that in we then use the  power rule and we can multiply the  exponents together  from here we can simplify the numerator  by factoring out 2 to the power 26 and  we can simplify the denominator by  factoring out 2 to the power of 18.  from here we have a factor of 2 to the  power of 10 plus 1 in both the numerator  and denominator so they cancel out then  we have 2 to the power of 26 divided by  2 to the power of 18 which will be the  difference of the powers that'll be  equal to 2 to the power of 8 we take the  square root of that which is equal to 2  to the power 4 which is equal to 16 and  that's the answer